i think if anything we're grateful to be
able to have grownish as a vehicle to
express even some of the ways
that young people are leading the charge
they're investing in private prisons cal
u
everyone should be talking about this
and they're not
this season on grownish we get to see
the students of cal u stage
a peaceful yet extremely powerful
protest
yara what would you say is the number
one piece of advice to those out there
who are looking to be a change maker
i don't even know if i'm in a place to
give advice i'm honestly so awe inspired
by my generation and i think
even whether it be the 100 days of
sustained protests that we saw this
summer
or the ways in which young people were
innovating in every single way to lead
the movement for social justice really
the lessons are evident in their action
i think if anything we're grateful to be
able to have grown-ish as a vehicle to
express even some of the ways
that young people are leading the charge
especially given the fact that you guys
wrapped these episodes
at the end of 2019 and
in the past year you all have continued
to use your platforms
to its fullest extent but yara what has
happened over the last year that has
given you hope for the future
it's important to remain hopeful because
hope is a belief in the future to
to begin with but honestly it has been
looking at my peers
and their dedication to change
especially the ways in which they've
continued to innovate i think
history isn't necessarily circular and
so many times we go through issues that
generations before us have but to see
the intergenerational support
coupled with the fact that people are
realizing that social justice and being
a change agent can really take any shape
or form and i think
we're really optimizing the change we
make because everyone is going back to
their respective sectors their skills
their passions their communities
and bringing messages of justice and
equity with them and i think we're only
more powerful that way
talking to the lovely chloe and hallie i
want to wish you ladies a big
congratulations just to start off on
your three
grammy nominations thank you what does
it mean
to see yourselves and other r b artists
be so celebrated this year not just at
the grammys but in the music industry in
general
it means the entire world to
my sister and i because we just love
creating together
and it really just bonds our sisterhood
so we're just creating really for fun
and for ourselves
and to know that other people appreciate
what we create in our living room
and our garage and just by having fun
and experimenting it truly means a lot
to us
and i can't wait to do that more
together and just continue to put out
music and i'm hoping and praying we win
a grammy this year we'll have to see
what happens
but regardless i'm really proud of my
sister and i'm proud of myself too
because we learned how to make the best
out of this moment with the whole
pandemic and as scary and as sad and as
heartbreaking as it is
we wanted to see and bring hope to
people and
love and light through singing and
performing so i'm really happy with what
the year brought for
us musically
[Music]
especially as creatives during this time
of just craziness of 2020 the pandemic
of everything going on
as a creative it's just such a beautiful
way
to get out your emotions in an outlet to
be able to have
music or have writing so for all of
these amazing
artists who have just been releasing
projects
i applaud them and i'm grateful for them
because it helps
get me through these times and i'm just
i'm so grateful for my pen and music and
everything because i truly feel like
it's just how
i can deal with life in general so
to all of the creatives out there i
truly feel that we're
doing something making something out of
this time
you ladies have given us the extremely
catchy grown-ish theme song
but we haven't seen skye and jazz sing
on the show since that epic brief
karaoke scene early in season two
[Music]
did you guys know they could do this
would you ladies be open to uh
sharing your singing gift on the show
again i'm
always open i just feel like it'd be
weird for jazz
and skye to be like track singers but
they like to sing in their free time so
be it i always sing so i don't mind
maybe we could have you guys debut new
music on the show anything in the works
oh well there's always stuff in the
works so you never know
you never know
[Music]
i am so excited about anna's journey she
has a lot going on
in these next episodes she's always been
the most conservative one in the group
both in her politics and her views and
in these new episodes we see her develop
like a deeper relationship with god
what has been the most rewarding and
most challenging parts for you in
bringing this character to life
the rewarding part is bringing the
character to life
um and especially in these next few
episodes i mean
her relationship with god is very
similar to mine and i was actually very
excited
to um take on that journey because
you know i went to the writers i was
like this is exactly how i felt the
first time i went to church this is
exactly how i felt when i was
going through that phase i'm happy that
i'm able to bring that to life and
actually be able to talk about it with
you
or with anyone um that talks to me about
it
um the challenges have been you know my
views are different from anna's views
so that's been a bit of a challenge but
at the same time it's educated me a lot
it's shown me a lot of grace and
understanding
and you know rather than you know having
my opinions
up in the forefront i've really took a
step back and really have tried to
understand
all sides to everything and i think it's
definitely helped me be a little more
understandable in this last year
but it's also you know for me personally
it helped me speak up
a little more so i think there's been a
couple not not a lot but a couple times
where like i looked at the writers i was
like
i literally cannot say this but you know
uh so that's
been the challenge you remember that uh
it was at a table read but that's been a
challenge but other than that i'm
happy to be able to you know portray the
story lines that they give me
and um bring anna to life especially in
this next journey
um throughout the show wow i've missed a
lot
emily we've gotta talk about nomi
because oh baby i miss her so much on my
screens you guys dropped a baby
bombshell on us um how do you think that
pregnancy and perhaps motherhood is
gonna change her view on the world
i think it has to right you know i think
for
that type of transition to happen where
someone a woman in this case know me
enters a place where okay i don't just
have to think about myself anymore i'm
not
my only priority i have somebody else
who i brought into this world who i need
to
consider first i think it's going to
change a lot especially for someone like
nomi who i think historically
has has really kind of thought mainly
about herself
first um it will be interesting to see
how those two things uh come together oh
oh single mom life has been a lot